Last time we saw Grant, he had just gotten the opportunity to expand the area of
his booth at the expo. Now it's 15 feet long and 20 feet wide. As excited as he
is about this, we know Grant. He always wants more. He wants to make this booth
even bigger. The person in charge of the expo is going to continue the
regulation he had before which is that if Grant's going to increase his booth
size, he has to do it by the same length in each direction. Let's call that
length x, just like we did earlier. However, there's one catch. The expo
authorities are adding another restriction to booth size. The area of a given
booth is not allowed to exceed 750 square feet. Considering this new rule that's
been put in place about area, how should we express the booth area? Are we going
to need an equation? Are we going to need an inequality? Or do we need something
else?